[Music]
what do you mean look out believers
justin is engaged he's really funny
we have a good time together he's just
really sweet he's a good kid he's a good
heart and I love him
he can confirm the Biebs pop the
question to Haley Baldwin in the Bahamas
a source close to the couple tells et
they are excited about the future and
the journey together quotes Justin
decided to propose to Haley in front of
a group people in the Bahamas but had
been planning to ask her for a couple
weeks now the ring is gorgeous
and Haley is over the moon with joy I've
had dreams about it long dreams
according to the source Justin got down
on one knee and asked Haley to marry him
Justin wanted it to be special
Haley was smiling from ear to ear and
said yes the two then embraced and the
crowd erupted with cheers following the
event his dad Jeremy took to Instagram
with a post that appears to reference
the engagement reading proud is an
understatement excited for the next
chapter
his mom also tweeted with an abundance
of love in a tweet that was later
deleted Haley's dad Steven shared
happiness for JB and HP as well as a
congratulations to Justin's parents the
couple has been spotted together
constantly since rekindling their
romance roughly a month ago I've gotten
to a place where I have like a core
group and people who are really
supporting me and encouraging me
[Music]
[Applause]
you